docteur Garnaud bonsoir bonsoir alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que le syndrome de
la personne raide expliquez-moi ça oui
en fait c'est une condition qu'on
appelle auto immune dans laquelle des
anticorps vont s'attaquer à une partie
du système nerveux qui permet
normalement la relaxation musculaire
vous comprendrez donc que si le système
permettant une relaxation musculaire et
défectueuse la personne va expérimenter
des contractions musculaires
involontaires incontrôlable qui vont
mettre les Muses dans un état raide ou
rigide puis là-dessus peut se reposer
des spasmes qui vont faire en sorte que
les muscles tout d'un coup se
contractent vous aurez donc compris que
une personne qui souffre d'un tel
syndrome va avoir de la difficulté avec
la fluidité de ces mouvements donc
évidemment ne pourrait ne pourrait pas
monter sur scène est-ce que ça se guérit
est-ce qu'il y a des médicaments
passez-moi mes questions très naïves
pour régler ça une fois qu'on a ça on
l'a toujours oui le plus important à
spécifier c'est que ce n'est pas une
condition de neurodégénérative dans
laquelle la personne va devenir
complètement atteinte et en décédé c'est
une condition pour laquelle nous avons
des traitements qui vont contrôler les
symptômes le plus fréquent qu'on utilise
le diazépam ou le Valium que bien des
gens connaissent c'est un agent qui va
permettre de faciliter la relaxation
musculaire et contrôler les symptômes
par contre on parle d'un contrôle
davantage d'une cure de la condition au
fil du temps c'est difficile c'est ça de
s'en départir complètement donc vous
dites on ne guérit pas on peut atténuer
les symptômes
calmer les spasmes des muscles mais on
ne guérit pas si c'est ça qu'elle a
vraiment évidemment on peut pas vous
prononcer je voulais pas examiner mais
on ne guérit pas de ça donc la question
tous les gens se posaient aujourd'hui
c'est est-ce que elle pourra remonter un
jour sur scène chanter bouger etc
c'est difficile de me prononcer sur ce
qu'elle pourra on ne pourra pas faire
parce qu'évidemment je ne connais pas
son son dossier par contre ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'il y a de l'espoir d'avoir
le contrôle des symptômes avec la
médication et en plus madame Dion dans
son allocution a bien spécifié qu'elle
était entourée de médecins et d'autres
thérapeutes pour l'aider à reprendre de
l'activité physique et se mobiliser pour
atténuer de façon globale ces symptômes
donc bien qu'on ne considère pas que la
maladie soit une condition entièrement
guérissable on peut quand même voir chez
des patients des rémission des symptômes
grâce à nos traitements donc
quand on dit aussi que c'est très très
rare est-ce que vous en avez vu vous
est-ce que vous envoyez c'est
extrêmement rare donc j'ai vu bon je ne
suis pas en pratique depuis de si
nombreuses années mais j'ai quand même
vu un cas c'est rare au point d'avoir
environ une personne sur un million par
année qui va être diagnostiqué avec ce
syndrome c'est plusieurs centaines de
fois plus rares que la majorité des
maladies neurologiques qu'on voit au
quotidien comme la sclérose en plaques
ou la maladie de Parkinson la majorité
des neurologues n'enveront pas de code
de leur carrière question avant de vous
laisser aller docteur Garnot est-ce
qu'on peut faire de mauvais diagnostic
dans ce genre où quand on a un
diagnostic qui est la personne raide
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on a
décidé d'aller publique parce que ça
fait longtemps qu'on dit que Céline on
se pose des questions en disant
qu'est-ce qui arrive des gens pensaient
que elle avait développé en quelque
sorte comme un caprice en disant oh la
pandémie ça a été le fan j'ai réussi à
revivre ma vie un peu mais il y a des
gens disaient faire de chaud et tout ça
mais quand vous connaissez Céline Dion
moi je l'ai vu souvent je l'ai
interviewé souvent puis Céline la scène
c'est son deuxième chez soi elle est
bien c'est dans son ADN et quand elle
dit dans son allocution dans dans son
vidéo que elle s'ennuie et qu'elle a
hâte de retrouver la scène et de rejouer
pour ses fans ça je la croise c'est
vraiment pas du théâtre mettez-moi en
perspective la tournée qu'elle reporte
une autre fois c'est une grosse tournée
oui oui c'était la c'est la tournée je
dis c'était mais ça va pas simplement
être c'était la tournée que rage qui a
commencé à Québec en septembre 2018 et
déjà dans les jours qui ont suivi il y
avait déjà eu des concerts il y a de qui
avait été reporté parce qu'elle avait
des problèmes avec sa voix fait
qu'est-ce que c'était déjà le l'état
embryonnaire de sa maladie on sait pas
mais au fil des années elle avait la
voix de plus en plus fragile après ça
vous donner des concerts ça a roulait
juste que à la mi-mars en 2020 et on
sait ce qui est arrivé tout arrêter dans
l'industrie du spectacle puis ça a été
la dernière fois que c'est bien de
monter sur une scène donc il y a des
dates comme ça prévues de cette tournée
cordage c'est incroyable c'est vendu
jusqu'en 2024 j'ai jamais vu ça moi une
tournée qui va s'étirer une tournée pour
un album souvent tu as des artistes qui
vont annoncer des retours au commerce
récemment qui annonce une tournée
d'adieu et qu'il les tirent qu'il les
tirent qu'il les tirent mais pour un
album pour un projet spécifique c'est
une des rares fois que j'ai vu ça est-ce
qu'on va se rendre jusqu'en 2024 ça
c'est la grosse question d'abord on peut
pas on peut toucher de faire des
pronostics qu'on vient d'entendre
docteur Garnaud mais on peut quand même
c'est légitime de se poser la question
est-ce qu'elle pourra encore remonter
sur scène mais ça c'est la grosse
question moi aujourd'hui en discutant
avec bien bien des dans les différentes
entrevues j'ai accordé ça va dépendre de
elle est-ce qu'elle veut remonter sur
scène pour être plus sédentaire et avoir
peut-être l'allure de Phil Collins
lorsqu'il est venu avec Genesis
récemment c'est sûr Céline Dion c'est
quelqu'un qui est fier tout ça qui est
assis puis il doit se déplacer avec ses
cannes on l'amène on l'aide et ça soit
puis il passe sa soirée à être sur la
chaise et à chanter est-ce que Céline
est prête à faire ça je ne crois pas que
comme l'impression qu'on va analyser
toutes les situations puis c'est quand
même dans ses mains ici les médecins
nous disent oui vous pouvez chanter
parce que l'inquiétude c'est même si
elle est traités est-ce que lorsqu'elle
sera en concert avec la voix manque ou
que ça amène différente réactions est-ce
que ça va lui tenter de prendre le
risque ça c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
questions qui sont bien ici pour ça j'ai
l'impression que tout a été déplacé à
l'année prochaine en 2023 au mois de
septembre j'ai l'impression que depuis
la mort de René Angélil ses coups dur
sur coup dur comme je disais on a
l'impression que c'est plus difficile
est-ce que c'est une impression est-ce
que c'est vrai ou c'est injuste c'est
différent je vous dirais c'est que bon
quand l'album premier album qu'elle a
lancé suite au décès de René ça avait
tout été organisé avec lui de son vivant
faites-le ça comme une continuité mais
quand elle est arrivée avec l'album que
rage les critiques ont pas été très
tendre à des endroits en plus elle a
vécu quelque chose de particulier elle a
établi une marque à l'effet que elle
s'était retrouvée en première position à
la première semaine de parution et ça
c'est parce que quand tu achetais un
billet pour son spectacle tu avais le
droit à l'album et dans ce temps-là
c'était recensé alors qu'après ça ça a
été modifié au niveau de de cet
acceptation là et là ce qui est arrivé
c'est que la semaine suivante est
surprouvée comme dans les positions 150
alors ça a été la chute la plus
verteigieuse pour un album fixé c'est
des drôles de situations comme ça qui
sont arrivés et honnêtement
mais je pense pas que ça l'affecté mais
honnêtement moi je pense pas que ce soit
meilleur album qu'elle a fait le
différent album plus solide mais ça
c'est moi qui pense ça mais bien des
gens pensent la même chose aussi pour
les critiques et la question que
j'allais vous poser comme d'autres qui
connaissaient bien ça c'est est-ce que
ça aurait été son dernier ou pas mais à
voir on va suivre en mesure de faire des
d'aller chanter en studio parce que si
voilà exactement de des albums sans sans
rarement des peut-être aussi que la
situation va lui permettre d'aller
passer du temps en studio ici il y a des
complications on va arrêter on va
repartir par après alors que quand on
est en direct mais là c'est différent my
Gauthier merci beaucoup de nous voir en
direct merci au revoir